[Thunder]
[Bat squeaks]
Villains, they’re calling us villains?
That’s ABSURD.
Yeah, we never thump our chests,
and we always donate to charity.
Ain’t that right, Rocco?.
Yeah, you’re fine
I mean, you’re a little clingy...
Listen, okay, it’s my fault.
I made some mistakes, but I’m a man, and
I take the blame.
And I just wanna say...I’m sorry.
Ugh, enough apologizing. I think
villains... kind of has a nice…
...RING to it.
So you want us to be bad guys?
Yeah, what are you talkin’ about?
You want us to be bad guys?!
You see, my whole life I’ve been the Golden Boy...
the Baby Face... the GOOD guy.
After last year, I think maybe
a little re-branding is in order.
And frankly, I don’t mind
this whole “villain thing.”
Yeah, I mean, we all got these evil goatees already, so….
Yes! Yes! Stroke your goatees gentleman
because we are EVIL now.
MUHAHAHAHAHA!
[Maniacal laugher intensifies.]
Well we are
a Superteam!
All the best players here to crush your dreams.
I don’t have enough fingers
for all these rings we’re gonna win.
HAHAHAHA!
Well, we are a Superteam!
Winning all the games and
destroying the league,
and if you think that’s a sin
Here’s the smallest violin.
Let’s go around the room, shall we?
Kevin, make me wanna burn your jersey.
Surely, I’d love to!
HAHAHAHA!
Well, hello there I’m KD.
You might know me as the better MVP.
I swear I just came here to grow...
By winning each game by FORTY OR SO.
I’m Klay. I play two ways.
I lock you down on D, and then I make some treys.
And then I’ll… uh...Um…
I forget what I was gonna say.
Well we are a Superteam
All the best players here to crush your dreams
I don’t have enough fingers for all these rings.
We’re gonna win.
HAHAHAHA!
Yes, we are a Superteam
We're the cheat code that destroys the league.
And if that makes you mad, here’s
some fire kicks for your dad.
Take it away, Draymond.
I’d like to formally apologize for everything I’ve done.
Though informally I must admit it was a little fun.
But I’m sorry to my fans,
to my teammates, and my owner.
Oh crap! I just snapped another picture of my boner.
I’m David West. I want a ring. Give that to me!
How dare you take a ring from
a finals MVP!
I’m Shaun, and my knees are back from the dead.
Say goodbye to the league. We're lightyears ahead!
Well we are a Superteam!
[Nut kick sound]
All the best players here
to crush your dreams.
I don't have enough fingers for all
these rings we're gonna win.
HAHAHAHA! Shoobie doobie doobie doo!
Yes, we are a Superteam!
Flopping on the floor like a drama queen.
But we don’t just bark. We bite!
See it live on national TV every night!
[Smash!]
[Explosion.]
ZAZA SMAAAAASH!
Zaza hear you want to be villain.
So Zaza bring you the heads
OF ALL
THE OTHER ALL-STARS
IN THE WEST!!!
Wow. Oh my there Zaza.
Love your attitude! But...
You might be taking the villain thing
a little too far.
There’s still some rules, buddy.
There’s still rules, Zaza.
You gotta take it easy, alright?
Nothing easy! Nothing easy!
We going to game 7 baby.
Game 7!
Game SEVEN!!!